so let's get a view on all of this we
can speak to the conservative pollster
Lord Robert Hayward a very good morning
to you nice to see you I mean label
we're expected to win this by-election
weren't they but what do you make of the
result and how much they want it by have
they got reason to really celebrate
today oh yes they have to be pleased um
they've got over 60 percent swings 13
it's good for cheer for the labor party
no question about it but the
conservatives will be relieved they got
over 20 there's a psychological thing
there and it's not quite as bad as the
opinion polls have been suggesting so
pleasure on the labor side relief a bit
on the conservative side well yes and
you talk about what the the national
opinion polls are suggesting if they
were to match that they would have had a
17 swing labor from the conservatives so
is that a source of disappointment would
you expect them to match those National
polls there's somewhere in the range and
there's no question that conservatives
will be relieved and it's it is below
what one might have expected rather than
above but labor quite reasonably can say
well the turnout was only 41 it was 70
at the last general election so I think
generally as expected no shocks but
definitely satisfaction for the labor
party well yes and not great for the
Tories either I mean this is not
something that's good news for varishi
sunak to wake up to he's pretty fresh in
the job how much of the blame should he
take for this I think he'll take the
view he's been in the job for just over
a month he knows the challenges the Tory
party know the challenges and it to a
large extent the collapse of the Tories
in the opinion polls
arose from the events right through the
summer into the Autumn and he will say
I've got to put put it behind me
which is what the message has been over
the last few weeks get on with the job
re-establish the economy deal with the
big issues whether it's immigration or
strikes or the NHS and convince the
government the next big electoral hurdle
will be a huge raft of opinion of local
elections next May and that's where the
real attention will turn to I mean some
people say that at this stage in a prime
ministeria ship that's not a word but
you know what I mean when you've taken
on the top job yes and so early on in
that job you might get a little bit of a
boost you might people might say look
there's a fresh leader let's give them a
chance no I think the sense has been
that the Tories have had a very very bad
summer uh into the Autumn uh he's taken
over an incredibly difficult
circumstances he knows what he wants to
do the question is whether he can
actually do it
um he's got a very very slight bounce
because
the opinion polls the Tories were in the
bottom of a very deep barrel and the
opinion poles showed that the Tories
have lifted themselves a bit off that
this result shows a bit better than the
opinion balls are showing
um so he might have had a slight bounce
he stopped the Tories just collapsing
into irrelevance
how worried will those MPS in the red
wall the so-called red wall see it's not
far from Chesterfield today oh it's not
just the red wall I sat in this studio a
few weeks ago and said that give them
the opinion polls the Tories couldn't be
clear that they'd got any safe seeds so
it's not just red wall all MPS all Tory
MPS will be looking at this result
they'll be looking at local government
by-elections because they're low they
are those each week and being concerned
there's no question about it the Tories
have got to make progress but what kind
of progress can they make when we're
heading into a winter of so far we've
got lots of strikes planned but we've
also got this terrible cost of living
crisis where bills are just going up and
up how can the Tories make any real
Headway before those local elections
there's no question they have a real
Challenge on on their hands but having
said that
um Rishi comes across to the public at
large as managerial his ratings are way
ahead of the Tory parties at his rate
things which will worry the labor party
are on a par with kirstelma depending on
which poll you actually look at so he is
showing that there is potential but cost
of living and Strikes clearly big issues
but
the end of my road today petrol prices
down again at the local petrol station
so there are some indications that there
are opportunities there for the Tory
party but Richie has to convince the
public at large that he can manage out
of this crisis whichever crisis one's
looking at and there's a lot of them and
just a quick question I'm curious to
know what you make of the fact that
Boris Johnson has said that he does
intend to stand again next time around
the Tories have set this deadline
haven't they for MPS come forward and
say whether or not they're going to
stand again we've seen some of the
younger MPS deciding not to Boris
Johnson says he will what do you think
that's also the psyche of the party
knowing that the former leader still
intends to stay on I I think it probably
says I want to continue to serve because
you'd be asking me that almost the
opposite question if he'd announced that
he was going to stand down isn't this a
comment so it's natural I think for
Boris Boris is a natural politician he
wants to be in the political world and
there therefore I think it comes as no
surprise and he's actually announced
what he has that he's going to stay on
at Oxbridge